since show business and society in the
world pretty much has changed
tremendously I feel like when I I
started my career was 12 in French I was
12
I'm 45 today and I don't know if I would
have if I would have the the patient or
because I'm a hard worker person but I
think it's so different the business
today than what the way I started I
don't know if I would start a career
today maybe I would have gone to clubs
and sing whatever I wanted and enjoy my
music I have no idea I feel for the kids
today they do they work so hard and they
have to do so much I'm not quite sure of
that Sammy I was asked about do you feel
sorry that for people who might have the
same talent as you they just don't have
the same opportunities and the same way
to get into the business they might be
deprived the amazing life that we find
ah it's not something that I can feel
sorry for because they don't know
different for me today I know the
difference because a 30 year career such
a longevity it's a miracle it's almost a
miracle really it's like amazing you can
have a hit but you have a career is way
way way different than that um I don't
know if I could feel like oh I feel
sorry for them I know that they have to
do much more but they don't know
otherwise they don't know differently so
what I know for a fact what's been
helping me and I this is something that
I hope they they have I hope they keep I
hope that they recognize that is a
family they're willing to work really
hard they're willing to sell their soul
and to really give it all excuse me I
just hope that they have wonderful
people that got always had throughout my
life and my career to protect me
to love me and to make sure that I'm
working and I'm doing the right things
that that's what I hope for for them you
mentioned that show business has changed
immeasurably since you started out and
just mentioned there that young artists
have a supportive family when you look
at someone like Miley Cyrus who's on
something is that in the press so much
yes we shouldn't single her out young
female artists in this day and age do
you think there is pressure to sort of
sexualize their performances
well Society is giving a lot of kids
pressure you know it's it's what we see
on TV it's what we see in magazines
everything is so retouched and show
business and TV is not real life but
what's hard is that everybody wants to
be famous and when you want to be famous
the fiction and what's on TV and the
showbiz in the magazine and and the
girls today it's a lot a lot of pressure
and the artists today they there's no
limit they they're willing to do a lot
and they will figure it out I mean it's
not up to me to tell you if it's wrong
or if it's right I'm glad that I didn't
have to do that personally for myself in
my own life if they're fine and they're
willing to do so I wish them luck and I
wish that I wish they are for me the
artistry part of it whether is like you
dress a certain way or you undressed a
certain way for me it's not even part of
the discussion for me it's down the line
the emotional balance of it wishing
wishing them luck wishing that they will
find a satisfaction and pleasure while
they're doing it and that it won't be
negative side down the line